[Musique]
on dit que le pain qui est cuit avec un
four qui a été chauffée au fado est
meilleur que l'autre
est ce que c'est vrai ah oui le ballon
surtout les meilleurs parce que ça
concerne beaucoup plus longtemps
savoir qu'il est fabriqué au levain une
ce qui demande une préparation longue
préparation
les vins sont celles soir ensuite il
faut comme ces valeurs du matin pour
avoir la première fournée vie d'ascète
limiteur qu'il faut compter au moins
sept heures dont deux ferme attention
pour avoir un bon pain au levain dit
voici lé trou dans votre pain
ah oui beaucoup comment ça se fait ça
parce que tu arrives pas expliquer tout
ben c'est tout un métier d'artisan
il faut beaucoup de temps pour
l'apprendre d'abord ils appellent ça des
alvéoles et ses trous là justement ce
qui empêche et qui donne la saveur du
pain parce que d'attaquer n'a pas de
trou n'est pas bon cette fabrication
n'est plus rentable alors pour gagner sa
vie il faut aller soutenir le mouvement
alors les pour ton show fait comment
maintenant bien de l'allant trophée sans
doute avec les fours intérêts
extérieurement le four à vapeur
voilà un chiffrage parce qu'il faudrait
bien se conformer ou ou abandonner cette
méthode kavala le métier
[Musique]